[Music]
if i were to pick a word
for 2020 what is it right this moment
it would be mischievous
i think that i've taken
a lot of things in myself way too
seriously in 2020
and uh i
i think i think i want to bring more
coyote energy
and kind of prankster mischievousness
into 2020. interesting so what does that
look like in you
like like like no mask wearing kind of
thing or no
no that's just being a dick dick face i
don't want to do that
no a coyote it's more yeah it's more
i think a playfulness and
a irreverence
not taking things too seriously uh
you know i'll give you an example i i
just the other day
threw up i love the original willy wonka
movie
with gene wilder and so i threw up this
animated gif
that is gene wilder sort of eating candy
saying the suspense is terrible i hope
it'll last
and i just threw that up and uh
it was hilarious to see
how people responded and because it's
it's
so kind of oblique and
vague that it acts as a rorschach test
for wait a second did you throw this up
like during the trump like
capital takeover today i no i threw i
threw it up right afterwards
oh jeez fuel in the fire dude
well you say yes i mean you say terrible
timing i think
that i want to cultivate
a insensitivity to
uh kind of
personality by consensus what i mean by
that is
if you look at a lot of people i'm not
going to name names but if you yeah
yeah no no i'm not going to cure the
manicured like feeds and stuff
well you just look at personalities
online over time who spend a lot of time
on social
and they become caricatures of
themselves because they have
certain behaviors rewarded certain
behaviors punished
certain behaviors left unapplauded
and they start to warp and bend their
behavior
to fit the most applause and
they turn into these like kind of creepy
caricatures
uh and i think that that i think that
that
ends up inevitably bleeding over into
their
real lives right i mean they're they're
off-screen lives and i think that's
really
something i want to be hyper aware of
which is why i don't have the social on
the phone
i'm using these like workarounds like
only pulp to post stuff
and i want to kind of hold
up a mirror that allows people to look
at their own reactions
also right so uh
i think that a lot of what i'll put up
in 2021 will be
uh rorschach tests and for people who
don't know that those are the inkblot
tests where they would put
lots of ink fold a piece of paper show
it to someone and say what do you see
and you know they might see a murderer
they might see a butterfly that might be
something else and then that is used as
kind of a
jumping off point for psychoanalysis and
that's not going to be everything i put
up but
i just think that life
is too short to take yourself too
seriously
and so first and foremost it's for me uh
but doing things that don't seem to have
a point
uh doing things that are beautiful just
because i think they're beautiful
they don't need to have some targeted
outcome roi or fill in the blank right
and just to
kind of loosen my grip on
whatever i think my identity is that's
been constructed over such a long period
of time and let's not kid ourselves
like the like identity can be revealed
but it's largely constructed
right and it's just you i think we get
so attached
to our labels of what we are and what we
aren't what we do and what we don't do
that it's a it's a it's just a
very socially reinforced trap that kind
of constrains
your awareness and sensitivity and
openness to the world
uh so yeah more coyote that's good
i mean the world needs i think the
problem that we've fallen into with
social media
and part of the reason why i don't like
having an account there is it just
becomes
um it's it's really it's it's it makes
me sad in some sense and that i see
it's always the best version of
someone's self like there's never any
like if he feels very very manufactured
oftentimes
and it's it's like it doesn't feel
authentic in the way that
it's always about good times there's
never any like any
i guess there has been more lately with
some of the the protests and so the
stuff that's come out on there but
i mean people myself included
tend to put just the best version of
yourself on there
versus just letting it all hang out
which i guess is what kind of what
you're saying in a sense that you're
you're just gonna have more fun with it
than just trying to create the tim
ferriss
like image up on on social media
yeah and you know i don't feel like i've
done
too much of that i mean i i do i've i
very deliberately put out stuff
that is true to me that i think
will uh you know could
irritate some percentage of my followers
just because
i i want to have some countervailing
force against
becoming this like dancing sock puppet
on the internet
so i do that to not
become too attached to social feedback
um but
you know not to turn this into a
discussion of uh
you know the social dilemma but
if you are constantly exposed to these
technologies like you are completely
outgunned
you're just you're completely outgunned
by
engineers and neuroscientists and
you know research and development teams
who
have uh for all intents and purposes
infinite resources
to turn you into
so you're just gonna keep a little rat
in a skitter box well yeah
i wanna i love that like the the ai is
gonna look at your feet and be like i
think tim would like this they're like
oh [ __ ] he posted a
yellow pony what what the hell right now
oh damn it like you're really
well i want to keep myself guessing too
right yeah i i don't i love that
yeah follow less of a script and you've
always been good at that though you've
always been like every like one in every
10 of your instagram posts everyone's
like what the hell is he
why is it a picture of that like it's
it's not it's clearly not
that manufactured feed which i've always
appreciated
yeah but well i thought was it a camera
well maybe i don't even remember
what it was but back when we were both
on
uh the apps i remember uh one of yours
was like
and deleting in three two one
[Laughter]
you to your to your credit sometimes
when i get a little far afield you're
like
i think you should probably delete that
it'll get a text from you which i
appreciate
well i can just tell well speaking of
like you said about my gummies i can
tell
when you're a little ham too every once
while someone will sneak out there
yeah that's true yeah it's true it's
dangerous dangerous to drink and uh
to drink and post that's a dangerous
habit
you